[Música]
ella es ivanka ziolkowski quien pinta
flores en las bayas pero esto no es sólo
arte callejero también es un símbolo de
renacimiento para la ciudad de mucha en
ucrania a principios de abril las
autoridades ucranianas entraron en la
ciudad después de que el ejército ruso
ocupara la zona durante más de un mes
fue así como el mundo entero descubrió
calles llenas de cadáveres fosas comunes
edificios hechos trizas y pruebas de
torturas y ejecuciones pero y banca que
es canadiense y tiene raíces ucranianas
ha intentado devolverle la alegría a la
ciudad así que pintó sobre los impactos
de balas que aún se ven en las calles
cuando comenzó la invasión fue a polonia
para ayudar a los refugiados que huían
de la guerra luego pasó más de un mes
como voluntaria en ciudades de toda
ucrania
conocí a un hombre llamado saia que
perdió a su hijo y su casa perdió su
casa por culpa de un bombardeo perdió a
su hijo que defendía a muchas y dijo no
hay más alegría para mí en esta ciudad
me voy
dijo ya no puedo ni caminar por mi calle
porque los impactos de bala me recuerdan
lo que perdí así que mire la valla había
muchos muchos impactos de bala no era
algo que yo pudiera arreglar así que
pensé que puedo hacer para darle a este
hombre un último recuerdo le pregunté
cuál era la flor favorita de su hijo o
la suya
estábamos de pie en su patio y miró
hacia abajo había narcisos creciendo
entre las cenizas y dijo a los dos nos
gustan los narcisos así es como empecé a
pintar esas flores y entonces todo se
encadenó el vecino de enfrente quería
flores y luego el de al lado también y
así hice todo este pequeño bloque en el
barrio llegué a conocer bien a los
habitantes y fue una gran experiencia
para ellos tener esto
según las autoridades locales al menos
400 cuerpos fueron encontrados en la
ciudad lo que llevó a la apertura de
investigaciones por crímenes de guerra
por parte de varios países dos meses
después de las masacres la vida vuelve
lentamente a la normalidad
cuando llegue esperaba haber muchas
atrocidades y eso fue lo que vi había
una calle la calle ia brusca que era el
corazón de la ocupación
ahí es donde estaban estacionados los
tanques allá es donde la mayoría de las
casas fueron bombardeadas pero incluso
allá fui a ver algunas de esas casas y
las vallas habían sido reparadas y
repintadas las casas también fueron
pintadas los techos fueron reemplazados
todo lo que no quedó completamente
quemado con la ayuda de los voluntarios
ha sido reemplazado casi por completo me
impresionó mucho ver que estas personas
no se dejaran desanimar por todo esto
este proyecto comenzó como un simple
intento de hacer sonreír a un hombre
pero mientras trabajaba había muchas
otras personas en las flores les
levantaron el ánimo fue estupendo ver
acá craneal no se va a quedar sentada y
dejar que los rusos tomen el control
este vídeo fue grabado el exterior de
una cárcel en el salvador estas personas
intentan averiguar si sus familiares
están retenidos adentro estas escenas
han sido habituales en los últimos meses
en este país centroamericano al menos
35.000 personas han sido detenidas desde
el 27 de marzo cuando el parlamento
declaró el estado de emergencia en un
intento por frenar la violencia de las
pandillas las autoridades acusan a los
detenidos de pertenecer a estas pero
según las ong también han sido detenidas
personas inocentes de forma totalmente
arbitraria lucre sea landaverde es una
abogada penalista que presta asistencia
gratuita a las familias cuyos familiares
han sido detenidos
desde que inició el régimen decepcion
nosotros hemos atendido alrededor
trescientas personas que venían a pedir
asesoría sobre los
que habían sido capturadas hemos
defendido a 28 personas y todas las
personas quedaron en el lugar
de capturas arbitrarias y
cumplir con unas cifras porque las
personas
hadas no tenían ningún vínculo con
ninguna pandilla porque los policías y
militares se metían a la taza oa los
trabajos de personas y los capturaban
sin una orden judicial pero además se
les está bloqueado del derecho a la
defensa por ejemplo no bloquean el
acceso a los expedientes a que
conozcamos en qué tribunales están
haciendo
es importante también señalar que antes
los procesados tenían derecho a que se
les hiciera una audiencia dentro de las
72 horas después de su detención hoy por
el régimen de excepción se extendió ese
tiempo en teoría a 15 días pero lo
cierto es que hay personas que tienen
más de un mes de estar capturadas y los
familiares no saben dónde están si están
vivos o no porque te han golpeado
muchísimo a los capturados y algunos han
fallecido entonces de la gente de los
familiares que aglutinan ahí está fuera
de los penales con la esperanza de que
en algún momento que liberen a sus
familiares el 9 de mayo las autoridades
reconocieron que 168 personas
encarceladas no tenían nada que ver con
las pandillas y que por tanto habían
sido puestas en libertad pero las
autoridades no han dado a conocer nuevas
cifras desde entonces también han muerto
18 personas detenidas desde la
instauración del estado de excepción
según cristóbal una ong local de momento
este régimen excepción durará hasta
finales de junio
eso es todo en los observadores de esta
semana muchísimas gracias alumbre
panadería artesanal por prestarnos un
lindo espacio para poder realizar la
grabación de este episodio recuerda que
si quieren informarnos de lo que ocurre
cerca de ustedes todos nuestros
contactos aparecen en pantalla
así que escriban nos y envíenos sus
imágenes de aficionados y quizás el
próximo observador de france24 sea usted
siga con más información en france 24 y
france 24 puntocom hasta pronto